what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
it's been a while since we've gotten
some guardians of the galaxy vol 3 news
but today we actually have some very
very exciting news about guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 news about the villain
and some pretty big plot details i think
so we're going to talk about who the
villain most likely is and then i'm
going to do a lot of connecting the dots
and tell you what i think is actually
going to be happening in guardians of
the galaxy vol 3. and i should warn you
james gunn and the cast really already
came out and said that people are gonna
die in guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
james gunn said this and the cast said
that they cried reading the script so i
think we can at least expect one death
in guardians of the galaxy vol 3 maybe
even more and since this particular
villain is most likely the villain of
guardians 3 it's understandable because
he is one of marvel's most powerful and
complex villains so let's dive into it
but if you're new be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel videos so first things first two
things that you need to know about
guardians 3. one adam warlock is
confirmed guardians of the galaxy two
left us with that atom post credit scene
but since guardians got pushed back and
james gunn was off of guardians and then
he was back on people were wondering if
he was actually coming well yes it is
confirmed he is going to be played by
will poulter and the second thing is is
that actor chukwudi owuji is confirmed
to be in the movie and is most likely
the main villain they haven't outright
stated that he's the villain but
everything that they've said about the
character leads us to believe that yes
he's indeed the main villain and the
main villain that i believe him to be is
the high evolutionary if you're not
aware who the high evolutionary is i'll
go over the origin briefly but he is
basically a god-like cosmic bean one
that has gone head to head with galactus
himself and it actually fits perfectly
with the story of guardians 3 if you
consider the sovereign and aisha and the
fact that adam warlock is coming and we
actually kind of get tied into the
scarlet witch which would connect
guardians to really earth because most
of what happens with the guardians
happens off earth but first and foremost
let's talk about what chukwudi recently
had to say about his character in
guardians 3. now chuck woody plays one
of the main characters in the peacemaker
series on hbo max the show's great and
he is great in it and in an interview
about his role with the hollywood
reporter he did talk about his upcoming
role with guardians he talks about when
he was first cast and about how powerful
his character is and here's what he had
to say to the hollywood reporter it was
near the beginning of production i knew
very early it was a crazy time for that
to be offered to me so early in
production it was a big deal for me i
think it was around april maybe march of
2021 but we didn't do the test screen
until may or something like that so it
was pretty early james had seen enough
of me at that stage to decide he wanted
me to be a part of guardians and when
asked to vaguely describe his character
in guardians this is what he said
powerful extremely powerful complex
james and i were talking about it but
he's certainly one of if not the most
complex character we've seen in the
freaking marvel universe so he's deeply
complex and deeply powerful and i hope
intriguing i hope i bring that to it now
to me right off the bat it sounds like
he is playing the high evolutionary now
there were some rumblings that have been
going on for quite some time now stating
that the high evolutionary might be the
main villain then of course we had all
of those mark hamill rumors mark hamill
is going to be playing the high
evolutionary but mark has come out and
denied those rumors and normally if
somebody denies rumors i would still say
well that doesn't mean anything but
since they did cast chukwudi i'm saying
that chuck woody is going to play him
and not mark and the high evolutionary
is complex and very powerful but it
makes a lot of sense for guardians
plot-wise and here's why the high
evolutionary once known as the man
herbert edgar wyndham started off as a
normal man well sort of genetically at
least but he started off as a man that
was very interested in the work of
genetic
nathaniel essek who is known as the
villain mr sinister so he began
experimenting with genetic manipulation
he would start by trying to evolve rats
in his mother's basement then at a
genetics convention he was given the
papers for blueprints to crack in the
genetic code in which he successfully
developed a serum that he called isotope
a now from here he managed to evolve his
pet dalmatian into a humanoid life form
with the intelligence of a chimpanzee
sadly the dog would be shot by poachers
and here's where things get very very
interesting he realized that his
creations wouldn't have a place in the
normal world so with the help of
jonathan drew the father of jessica drew
who is spider-woman in the comics they
moved to wondergore mountain and as some
of you may know this is where the
scarlet witch and quicksilver were born
there they discovered a ton of uranium
which they used as funding they built a
citadel of science and got moloid slaves
now eventually they would find out that
the uranium was poisonous jessica drew
got sick and jonathan left to avoid
getting sick as well but windham stayed
and he made himself a suit of armor this
armor protected him from the poisoning
and from here he made genetic
breakthroughs evolving animals into
half-animal half-man type beings calling
them the new men he'd then begin to
train these men in combat and chivalry
and they would be dubbed the knights of
wundergor and they referred to him now
as the lord high evolutionary now from
here things get a little weird using the
darkhold baron russoff attempted to use
it to heal himself but what he actually
did was freed c'thun the ancient elder
evil god on the same night a pregnant
woman named magda visited the citadel to
seek refuge now they managed to send
c'thun back but a part of c'thun
actually touched the girl this of course
is wanda maximoff who would later go on
to have chaos magic because of this see
how it's all starting to connect and now
i'll connect it even more he eventually
converted his citadel into a spaceship
and then he left earth exploring the
stars with his new men and trying to
find another planet eventually he did
find another planet and he tried to
replicate earth now he actually had
captured the hulk at this point but his
new men started to revolt against him
and they attacked him now the high
evolutionary had a serum that he wanted
to give hulk that would advance him a
million years but since he himself was
about to die he used it on himself to
heal himself and the result was that he
turned himself into a god-like being he
was then kind of repulsed by himself so
he devolved the surviving newman back to
their original animal states and then he
willed his own existence to dissolve and
he became one with the cosmos now
eventually he would take human form
again to finish his creation
counter-earth but unfortunately one of
galactus heralds found out about counter
earth and galactus decided that he
wanted to devour that planet now he went
up against the high evolutionary and
galactus did beat the high evolutionary
now luckily somebody tricked him to go
into a different planet but check this
out the high evolutionary actually
adopts adam warlock and he is the one
that actually gives adam warlock the
soul gem and eventually when the
beyonders attack counter earth they
manipulated adam warlock into killing
the high evolutionary but he was later
revived by moon dragon and adam
warlock's counterpart her now her is
aisha from guardians of the galaxy vol 2
who we believe is making adam warlock
but perhaps the high evolutionary is
actually behind the sovereign because if
you think about it it makes perfect
sense they are a race of what they
believe to be perfect beings in fact
they no longer procreate the normal way
they simply make their race this kind of
sounds like the high evolutionary since
he's about genetic mutation and
evolution so that's what i'm thinking is
happening in guardians of the galaxy vol
3. i think the high evolutionary is
actually in charge of the sovereign i
think aisha works for him and i think he
is actually going to be the creator of
adam warlock and if you're wondering
about this complex and ultra powerful
character here are his powers superhuman
intelligence telepathy telekinesis
precognition and cosmic awareness matter
and energy manipulation size
manipulation and he has sentient armor
which gives him superhuman strength
durability and vast regeneration
capabilities he's basically a god and as
you can see he is a very complex
character eventually he would go back to
earth in the comics and kind of become
unstable he would kind of go crazy and
kind of get evil which is why i think
they're saying that this character is
complex but also ultra powerful because
he has the powers of a god essentially
so i think that the guardians of the
galaxy definitely are not done with the
sovereign and i think the leader of the
sovereign is the high evolutionary who i
believe will be played by chuck woody or
would you but let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below do
you think it could be somebody else or
the high evolutionary and let me know
how excited you are about guardians of
the galaxy vol 3. don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you